all right just doing a quick hit with
you guys because I saw this story this
morning and it combines two of my
favorite things star wars and lesbians
and I'm sitting here with my favorite
lesbian war character your favorite Star
Wars what would your Star Wars character
name be well sorry
Darth Vader Darth Kader I don't know
that's like a gay thing up to be honest
this character that you're about to
discuss what is her name I don't know
her I know her name you know her name
what is it always mock Mars yeah yeah
yeah come on
all I hear is muff wars and I don't know
why like that that would be my name all
right
in one sense I'm like loving it but
another I'm like this is like a really
blatant reference yeah all right what
the hell are we talking about so I saw
this morning that a new Star Wars book
is being written with the official Canon
that means it's like officially part of
the Star Wars universe not just some
like offshoot things as an official star
part of Star Wars universe and it's
gonna be the first lesbian character so
what's your name again I'm off Mars
I think I'm assuming it's pronounced oh
it's mo oh ffs yeah I'll say muffin boys
yeah so as my you're my professional
lesbian you you feel good that lesbians
have now made it into a galaxy far far
away
oh yes I feel great we're taking over
the entire planetarium I mean I feel
good about it but like I can't get past
much like I just want to see what she
looks like because I picture like this
big like character like you know Meatwad
from Meatwad I'm gonna I'm putting a
hunger force where it's like this big
like what of me like a big muff being
you know you don't want like a Jabba the
Hutt lesbian you want like a mortgage no
I want it to be like a giant mom oh you
what yeah I want it
yeah or if you're gonna go with that
just go all out oh so you don't want to
lipstick lesbian Jedi
you want that you know I'm not that
that's been done but I'm saying like the
whole like hot lesbian thing has been
done so much I want this to be like a
menacing muff that likes eats things
you're so in the lesbian world that
you're over HotList I'm not actually
summer
I want a man-eating mom you want big-ass
u-haul lesbian yes that's incredible
but so the everyone was freaking out
because this is the first gay character
in Star Wars but wasn't c-3po gay yeah
exactly I think there's freaking out
because the first Leslie was a total
clam
yeah he yeah he was like total like yeah
oh absolutely I think they had a
relationship c-3po
alright well that's all I've got on this
incredibly important topic but I will
leave with this what's next for lesbians
good god what are lesbians gonna do next
well I'll be running for president in
the year 2016
um no I mean once you've made it to Star
Wars there's nothing else you're good to
go
I mean there's where else he's gonna go
you know she's gonna be a bad guy though
did you see that so she's actually is
gonna be like my fury oh yeah is that
bad for lesbians that they're bringing
in a lesbian and she's gonna be a bad
guy don't you a lesbian what a badass
yeah yeah I wanna fat Muffy eating
people lesbian character and that's it
final final statement and there's
nowhere else we can go from here well
that's exactly what you're getting so
you're lucky anyway are you guys down
with an official Star Wars and lesbian
let us know the comic